here's the debate
[Music]
okay so we're officially live yes
episode 142 with the one and only
francis ingano who by the way you know
there's a lot of people you can say
are the most feared man in the world the
best fighter in the world whoever you
want to call
our guest today may be the most feared
man in the world today let me give you
some statistics for you to be thinking
about if you don't know about uh how
strong his punch is so i think u.s
performance center
did a uh ufc ufc ufc performance center
tested to see how powerful his punch was
imagine a ford escort okay if a ford
escort comes full power full speed at
you and hits you it's the same power as
his punch okay if you grabbed a 12 pound
sledgehammer and you went all the way
back and you hit anything that's the
same exact power you get if you get
punched by him and on top of that his
punch packs 96
horsepower francis it's great to have
you on here today thank you very much
patrick
even though the introduction that you
just did i didn't
feel like it was me
[Laughter]
when did you know when did you know if
you hurt people you're gonna destroy
like you're gonna hurt people when did
you know your punch was that powerful
i think everybody punch is powerful it's
relative right it's depend of what
you're hearing and how you're hearing
you know um
and everybody has this kind of like
superhero like
feeling in him like i'm the man you know
we all have that but uh you always have
to you always question yourself
am i really the man
you know i need to try to test that
with on the other men to find out if i'm
really the man
yeah interesting so so
do you remember your first fight because
you know fights you go and you're afraid
you're like i don't know you know what's
but do you remember your first fight
where you hurt somebody
and you said i may have a strong punch
than others or you don't have a memory
of that no you don't think like that i
mean that jaws is statistic but i think
you don't work in there i'm like i'm the
strong pension sure yeah i mean you can
be um i always like this quote from uh
ed atlas from the grid 80 which he
always say you can have the biggest
muscle but if you don't have a delivery
system it's useless because you want you
want
and reach any target and you want you
can't destroy anything
so he you rather have a small pistol
like a nine millimeter but work uh
with a good delivery system so you can
hit something therefore if you're
hitting an elephant even though you can
kill him you can kill him one bullet but
at least you're causing damage and over
time you will take it down so the most
important thing is the delivery system
well i mean
if we if we could show the greatest
knockouts and how you got people to
tap out or the pain you bring upon
people
it's it's incredible seeing the way you
fight by the way can we bring up his
instagram account i just want to check
on how's your health how's your leg
doing after all the procedures you've
gone through uh it's been very rough um
it's a tough process because i wasn't
really i didn't really know what i was
going to put myself into which is a good
thing because if i knew that is going to
be
this
horrible maybe i could have like
hesitate on the surgery but i didn't
know so i went there um free-minded and
the surgery went where everything is
going well actually
but
still a very tough process the
rehabilitation process yeah the
injury and the pain you know uh the
irritation and everything you know very
and then also the fact of being um
of being a dependent you can do anything
you have to call a friend out to drive
you or to uber or stuff you know you can
i mean
doing
daily basis stuff is like
very hard francis how long is the
recovery process how long are you going
to be in crutches how long are you going
to be you know on the sidelines it's
step by step like with the crutches uh
they give you about four to six weeks
with crutches and then uh stuff like uh
before you work about the same
time but um
that doesn't mean you're here you know
it's just the first step you're just
strong enough to be able to like
work on your own and then after that you
have like until maybe three to four
months to be able to jog you know to
have that stability on your knee to have
your acr or your mcl strong
just enough to hold you on that ground
when you're not pivoting and by six
five to six months you are able to do
every activities that you're pivoting
such as like boxing even like wrestling
uh jiu jitsu but very light
and uh
until nine months that you're
probably
nine months to one year that you're 100
recovery nine months
yeah if everything so in all likelihood
you might not fight into the beginning
of 2023. i don't want to put a timetable
on this this is your world baby or the
end of 2022 okay or the end of 2022.
that's the timeline who is what other
athlete is your injury comparable to
a lot of athletes has those injury you
know uh you always walk around basically
uh i'm in vegas so i'm all the time at
the us api and you will see people
coming from all uh around the world with
uh
for the rehab for their uh injury and
most of the time going to be like acl
mcl or lcr you know
even pcr or whatever meniscus
but
you know
until you're there you don't really know
what it is you know at least at least
you're in vegas and they have good
centers that you can rehab better right
i'm assuming they have a good facility
there to help you expedite the process
absolutely i mean the facility uh day is
great we have a very good quality of
physical therapy of people there
at the ufc performance institute
i think is
the best you know
for for my experience because i was even
hurt before the fight and they heard me
to strengthen my legs and do everything
you know so
put me uh
build my
other muscles enough to put me in the
confidence to go into a fight with that
type of injury i think
just you're talking about the fight with
cyril gone yeah you saw this fight right
pat of course we watched this so how
injured were you at that fight it was
this injury i was uh acr
got it because because the the way you
fought that fight is not the way you
fight the fight
you it's slightly different the way you
you fought it everybody was kind of
watching and you'd read the commentating
you'd see what some of the experts are
saying but
what i think ended up happening with the
fight is you earned respect because you
beat him in his strength rather than you
know what people thought the style you
were going to take am i am i off on the
assessment some people gave um no you're
not off i think uh those who were off
uh was those people who was thinking
that you know because uh not because you
haven't seen uh
me
display cert some of my skill
doesn't mean i don't have it oh it
doesn't mean i'm not practicing you know
i go to practice every day every week
and i practice everything
um
but
i don't know if it's like fortunately or
unfortunately when i go to a fight
am i some sometime the fight goes by
really quick after a few seconds or a
few minutes so i don't have to display
all those
techniques or all those discipline
which in i have no problem with that but
as far as my last fight
um
i didn't have many arsenal in my pocket
because like uh i couldn't move uh
properly i was so concerned so afraid
basically like when the fight started
i'm like
oh maybe i should listen to the doctor
maybe i should listen to my team maybe i
should have i should have listened you
know
because
i don't know about my knee i'm not sure
about these you know and
i was fighting myself you know and i was
very uh
slow on
on everything every reaction and
reaction i was kind of like a second
behind
to reaction because i was thinking about
me fighting myself until i get past that
before i step into the fight but
honestly like getting into that fight it
was jersey like um for me
the only reason that i go to that fight
he was my honor you know um
[Music]
knew that i wasn't like hundred percent
but uh just trust the fact that i'm just
a fighter you know
i've been in a lot of
[ __ ] in life so
and i handled myself out of it pretty
good so
yeah but by the way just out of
curiosity i uh
uh uh we have a guy we were looking at
today to invite for uh the podcast the
gentleman that he wrote a book about
fear you know what i'm talking about
we're talking about upstairs how do you
view fear how do you process fear
yourself especially the life you've
lived what is fear to you and how do you
treat it how do you manage it
i think fear is something which is very
important fear is something that you
have to have you know uh
and therefore uh you develop your
ability to uh
overcome that to surpass the fear that's
what make you a better man you know
i don't trust people who say they are
not afraid that they have no fear i
don't trust them yeah because that fear
is i mean fear sometimes it's just a
knowledge of a situation that you're
into and then you have to be aware of
the uh
dangerousity of that situation and be
careful and
as soon as you're aware of the danger
the that's the first step of your
defense but if you are not aware of it
that's the festive step of your defeat
because you're exposed you think there's
not a danger but
fear come and
acknowledge you that there's something
you have to be careful
and therefore all your senses are ready
for whatever it's coming to you so i
think fear is something that is very
important and
if you realize if you look at it
everything that you have done in your
life which is very important you always
have that fear that stress
you're always nervous even whether it's
like um apply for a job or uh go to a
i don't know uh exam or whatever
everything that is very important you
have that here because you have you
acknowledge that there's something
important here i have to put all my
attention so that's what's kind of like
beautiful so the fight you had with
ghana when you went in when when when
were you able to control your nerves was
it the moment the fight started or
before you entered the octagon
i don't know if
i would say i control the nerves because
um at first i didn't understand and i
honestly at first i thought it was just
me i'm like man how can i be so big and
be
and feel fear and be afraid
then we with experience i realized no
that's exactly how it works and then i
kind of like check around then i realize
everybody has that feeling and that's
what made you a champion that's what
make you a fighter you're fighting
against uh
um something that you're fighting
against yourself at first you know
you're fighting to overcome something to
surpass something there's a challenge
which is your fear that you have to
overcome you know and then therefore i
kind of like just manage just accept it
yes i'm afraid that's mean i'm ready
uh i'm aware that something no good is
coming off my way i'm in danger so okay
i have to defend myself i also trust my
ability to defend myself
you know so
those combined kind of like
be like a upside for me
when before when you're when because
you're saying doctor maybe doctor's
right maybe this person's right maybe
that person's like i shouldn't fight
the people that were telling you maybe
not to fight or the people that were
telling you to fight
when did you make the decision that you
were gonna fight was there ever a
breaking point that you said i'm not
gonna fight uh no okay because even the
first day that the doctor uh gave me a
report after the mri
uh i think he was just expecting me to
call out the fight and um
i didn't want to do anything at that
moment that i could have regret like
one or two weeks after and that was like
three weeks out
so i decided like okay i'm keeping this
moving on and see what's happened
if one week or two weeks after
it doesn't get any better or get worse i
think i have no choice
but
i mean
i still think
i mean
there was a part of me who also believed
that that could be a advantage on me to
be very uh to be to
feel that fear
to know that i know i'm not 100 of my
capacity and be very aware of a danger
and at the moment that i'm aware of that
danger and on my um
on capacity i think i'm more uh
thoughtful
than when i'm like oh i'm good you know
let's go to war i'm like no don't do
that you're no good
you have to think about it differently
to approach it differently so for
instance for people that don't know your
story you got from where you came from
to america like if you can take a minute
and just give your background on how you
came to america because as an immigrant
myself you know america is like i
remember the first time i landed and i
went to the airport i'm like i can't
believe i'm in america
what was your journey from where you
came from to come in america
where um
from where i came from to america um
it's a little
complicated so this is like a two-step
story
like when i come to america even the
first time that story was different from
where
i left my country the first time
because i came in america the first time
i had a job
they picked me at the airport with a
limo brought me in the four-star hotel
four-star hotel you know check me out
and
have people around me
and uh i think that day i called my mom
i'm like hey
your son has made it
yeah
because growing up my dream was always
to go to america yeah but how i don't
know
so i didn't see myself like coming in
america
in the red carpet as i did the first
time so my first day in america
not only i was in the fly
um
there was somebody at the airport
waiting for me
taking my suitcases you know
bring it in the car
dr drove me to the
hotel
then they checked me in i wasn't
speaking any english but they were so
like oh mr gano this mistangano that
i'm like damn finally in america what
city did you land in orlando or of
like in orlando it's it's walt disney
world that's what it's known for over
there
i mean what kind of
pageantry was going on when you got
there no really but i think like at that
moment
he was all america everything that i was
seeing around
uh was so impressive and just the idea
that i'm in america that america that
i've been thinking about you know like
growing up uh
um i've been naming myself like american
boy or the staff and they've been naming
me
with a lot of nickname you know um
because i loved america and i always in
america but that's the way that i came
in america
was a red carpet
but
it's a different story compared to where
i went in france in europe you know
that's is a different story that's when
i migrated there and that wasn't fun at
all
you know
because i left my country first of all
without knowing where
i was going and i couldn't even tell my
family
because uh when you tell somebody that
you're leaving the first question is
like to where
where i don't have no destination so
you once again you're crazy you're out
of your mind oh you're going somewhere
that you don't know where you're going
you know
and that's how i left and
it took me
over a year
then uh
i mean i went i get i and ended up in
morocco and trying to go to cross and go
to spain
and um
it was a long process a tough process
you know and i was there for one year
before i made it so we were attempting
attempting like uh in the ocean with the
um
inflatable boat
like those small boats that they use in
the swimming pool
um
copper time
i think i fell six times
i fell uh and then i've been in that
thing so much that i
ended up became a captain even though i
don't know how to swim but i know how to
like put the boat in the water to how to
check the weather how to manage the wave
and everything and put the boat in the
water put my um
my friend inside and start a paddle so
that was good enough to be a captain
you know
we're trying to uh defenses uh to go
because there's two lands in a
morocco
uh which belongs to spain
uh in the west is celta and in the east
is melia
norway's are not east it's malia so
and those are just protected by fences
multiple fences and by wire security on
this side security and on other sides
high security but we're always like
trying to
find a blind spot to like attempt
and sometimes we succeed sometimes we
fail
most of the time we fail because the
security is so high with infrared
everything that they have to uh protect
the
the border
because the barbed wire is on the
about
i would say uh 10 miles
you know and that's all the
uh the border
so
try and that couple time fell
fair in bad wires and all the stuff
but um
always loved water even though i didn't
know to swim and had a feeling that
that's where i get admitted it's crazy
yeah even till today
swimming
uh i have trying to take some courses
you know i have a poo in my
in my house i'd love to meet your
teacher i'd love to see who teaches you
how to swim like to hold you that
picture of holding here no no no no no
no no
no no
she'll get it
can i ask you a question she is this big
she couldn't hold she can't hold no no
you don't know what
two stories they're they're totally
different but they're almost similar
because i don't know if you know pat's
story he got out of iran when there was
a war going on with iraq at the time i
believe
um
you escaping i mean people that aren't
familiar with your story the the getting
from morocco to spain people die
thousands of people die oh on that trip
okay so this isn't like oh i tried to
get into the boat
people die
constantly so
this this is life or death situations
here right
how have these life and death situations
fleeing um
on a boat to just get to freedom fleeing
iran to get to freedom in a refugee camp
in syria how's it shaped your mindset
and and
because you're a fighter but he's also a
fighter in the business world
this is a question for the both of you
like this also goes to americans hey
i've had a pretty good life even though
i was a very middle class normal like i
haven't had to fear for my life what is
fearing for your life for the both of
you done to your mindset
okay
so um
what you have to understand is
first you have to understand the
beginning
because for somebody to let your family
and your country and everything and just
pack a small backpack
leave
does mean you have i mean
if you have a little bit of comfort you
can do that thing because it's just
crazy right
so uh you must be like
um
in a very challenging life to be able to
take those decisions and stand by
you know
because it's not easy though like to
stand
wake up someday
pack your back and live to go where you
don't know you never cross the border of
your country and you have to cross
country by country because i didn't just
left from cameroon and get to morocco i
went from cameroon uh
uh
nigeria then nigeria put that upside
down i'd like to see where cameroon is
versus morocco versus spain that
crossing that channel right there so i
went to cameron then nigeria then niger
then algeria we have to cross the
sahara desert this to go to um algeria
and then from algeria to um
morocco right you know and all this is a
place and you're walking this entire
time how are you getting around no a car
everything okay snake because also
there's like a border control there's a
security yes in nigeria we are we are
borders this isn't
you know you're saying i left cameroon
to get to spain like this is the that's
not right
yeah exactly 50 miles he took like four
he took 40 it took me 14 months
to make it because like yes he's he he
look he's like very strict like that but
remember you have to go all this
yeah uh you have to go uh against all
this immigration process the law in
every country yes when you're in a
nigeria he's still okay because you're
uh the neighbor's country and
the circulation is still like free then
you get in niger
yes
we are all sub-syrian um
uh country but
we look a little
bit different though so even there the
um
[Music]
body control the immigration police when
they see you
when they see you they just realize they
just know that this is a stranger and
that route is like known for like
immigration so it's kind of like a big
uh
business there to control immigration uh
you know
stop them from
afloat to
europe
then you get to algeria
you're completely different like you're
outstanding
by your skin color so you can't hide
anymore you can pretend to be algerian
then you have to go to this uh
uh
passport stuff like oh i recognize like
this passport looked like me like you
can you buy it can you afford it yeah
oh buying a fake passport you're saying
yeah if you need to go from somewhere to
somewhere yeah
free circulation in some country you
need you need to have an id
the id who looks like you
you will you stand by hi i'd like an id
of the uh ufc heavyweight champion of
the world uh do you have anything that
looks like no sorry sir yeah but the
problem is that uh
um
[Music]
immigration wise my country and all
those countries need a visa there is not
a visa free so i have to have a visa but
i knew that i couldn't afford a visa
because yes before the uh
approach your visa you have to prove
that you have certain studies in life
you have to prove that where you're
going you're going for some business
matter and then you're going to come
back you know
and then that you can afford that you
can afford the trip you can afford it
every you can afford a hotel you can
subsidize your trip your whole trip you
can prove any of that bro so what do you
what can you do
just sneak out
craziness how are you processing this
path well listen
there's a reason why he is who he is you
know
i think that experience of being raised
in that kind of fear
uh it gives you a very
special
unique feeling that others are not gonna
have it's a very very unique experience
you can go through to finally come here
yeah
to finally come here but what i wanna
ask you so first couple fights i think
two three four fights was in france yeah
then was in switzerland then i want to
say it's in bahrain then you have your
fight in 2015 in orlando yeah is that
the first time you came to the state yep
so that's the first time you came to the
states for that fight absolutely i got
you okay so so your first few fights are
in europe yeah and at this point as
you're coming i think your first fight
is in 2013
uh when you got started and then you
kind of went through your uh uh
when you came to orlando were you
already like had you already kind of
make some noise for yourself where
people kind of knew there's this guy
that's coming here that can really wreak
some havoc on some people
yeah
um
because even when i started in france i
mean i took my first fight i was what
three or four months in the
in the sport and i was just there to try
and then uh wanted to like have a
complete experience and then they say oh
there's a fight here would you take it
you know i'm like yes why not so that's
how i get my first fight
you know uh and then i get a second one
and for me i was going
just to try those two fight
he was a tournament so i was going to
win the tournament and then move on
complete the experience and move on
but you know like on this what i say
sometimes um
there's a destiny some a lot of stuff
happened for some reason and everything
sometimes uh stuff happens sometime so
like just put you to some part
because if i were to win the second
fight
i would have
done with mma but the problem
i lost the second fight decision
and
for me
living on the on defeat
wasn't a right info
it sounds like i was quitting
yeah it sounds like i was living in the
pop people opinion that i have quit
and i couldn't see myself
in that
in that thought so i decided to go back
and fix it
but
little trap
for four months later i have another
tournament because those two first five
was free obviously um i have another
tournament and um
i fought i won get some money
i'm like not bad
you know
i
was that your first time you ever made
money fighting
yeah which which one the first first
fight you had in france no no no that
third fighter the third and the fourth
yeah i got you because it was a
tournament he was two fighters yeah
because you said the first one they
didn't pay you yeah yeah you remember
how much you got when you won that two
thousand euro two thousand so that's
2500 bucks american yeah about and how
much did that change your life that 2
000 euro
no i mean 2 000 euro can change your
life but
i was very happy about that you know by
the time i was already uh working in the
nightclub i had a friend who was
bringing getting me in the nightclub
sometime
[Music]
as a substitute so
i had a little bit of money i have
already like sent money in uh
my to my mom
so
he wasn't my first money but he was like
my first big money
and what's happened i just took the
money and go put it under the mattress
save that money oh yeah
[Laughter]
so then you have your sixth fight in
orlando
uh at this point uh you're saying people
are starting to realize who you are yeah
are you already starting to even in my
first my two first fight people was even
in france people i'm like what the hell
is this
you know like where do this guy came
from he's just
it's not normal yeah you know like
and then right away
people didn't want to find me anymore
like i have a lot of fight we'll get we
got cancelled in france
like a lot and it was so frustrating
that at some point
promoter they just started to pay me
when they get my fight cancer because i
would go there and then be in the locker
room and then warm up
you know and we were fighting in like a
little gymnast and then maybe like your
locker room would be here your opening
locker room will be there maybe he will
just hear how you're hitting me and
he'll tell his coach like
um
you know i'm not really ready you know
all this stuff and they can't cancel on
you
constantly and at some point i'm like i
can't do this i was so frustrated the
promoter and he really understood and
i'm like okay
at least take your pay and go home leave
me alone
i was happy with that dude so
did you hear what he said the guy you're
saying that your opponent is hearing you
warm up and they decide to cancel the
fight and quit some time yeah
so i had a lot of fights get cancer in
france gotta love you imagine that gotta
love that to be honest
where your opponent is like yeah i don't
want to fight i don't think so
prior to 2013 did you have a lot of
training or you're just a street fighter
no no i didn't had a lot of training i
had a few um
a little bit of boxing training i was
more boxing at that time you know more
boxing style because i don't know
anything about mma but i have done
boxing for a little
for a little bit and um that was what i
was going there for
did you have somebody like did you look
up to a boxer growing up were you like
an ali fan were you a tyson fan where
was it tyson you were a tyson finally i
mean not like i was a tyson fan i'm a
tizen fan yeah make sure lifetime yeah
makes sense lifetime you liked his style
of fighting just yeah he's incredible
for me like he's the best like when i
see when i even still today when i watch
thousand fight it's like
it's like a master class like explain
people how to box like okay this is what
they teach you
job job right job job cross jab jab open
code how this is how you move your your
head this is how the body
i mean he was like
like a class
now let's talk about a few things at our
current event which is something a lot
of people are interested in so your
fight ends
um
with uh uh cyril and you win the fight
and one of the biggest controversies was
hey
where is dana to put the belt on and not
to put the belt on he's addressed it
you've addressed it but i'm curious to
know what your
thoughts are going to be at this point
dana comes out and says listen i
actually walked out of the arena right
after the co-main event because there
was stuff going on that i was dealing
with and i can see that happening when
you're running a business this is a big
fight though that you were having for
anybody to think that i was showing any
type of disrespect towards francis i saw
francis all week you idiots i shook his
hand i said hi to him i was out there
for stare downs the whole thing so for
anybody to think that there was some
type of disrespect towards francis i
wasn't out there for michael bisping
versus luke rockhold's fight either
because i was dealing with some stuff i
sprinted from back i didn't even have my
jacket on i only had my shirt on to go
and put the belt on bisping but i
couldn't make it out there to put the
belt on francis so at this point
everyone said what they've said
how did you feel afterwards when he
wasn't there did you guys have a
follow-up conversation together
personally
i didn't care
i made my statement that night
i was happy
you know and um
[Music]
i don't know
if that's true or not
i don't care
what i do know is like i made my
statement
it wasn't about the belt it wasn't
around about
dinner wrapping the belt around me or
the press conference or anybody by the
way
nick manor which for me is a great guy
wrap the belt
around my waist and
that wouldn't be a problem for me
maybe he has a
a situation going on
i have no problem with me grabbing the
belt around my waist you know i'm very
cool and very happy uh with me
um
doesn't mean
anything
things was great maybe people are having
this speculation because of our
situation
the state of our situation
but it's possible that
something happened you know uh
that he was out for some business
but um
i don't care
i mean
you can ask people for so much but the
only thing that you can the biggest
respect that you're gonna have is you
respecting yourself standing by
what you believe
and then making your point and that's
what i did that night so whatever was
around it i don't care francis where are
you at now like you know p people want
to people enjoy seeing you fight it's a
very uh there are certain people that
draw you draw hands down if you got a
fight people are buying that
pay-per-view because you're just that
kind of an electric electrifying fighter
that people want to see
have you made up your mind on what your
next moves are are you
because there's speculation of ufc but
you're talking about tyson fury there's
a lot of different things that are
coming up
what are some of your plans that you're
thinking about when they can talk about
i mean uh i don't have a i haven't made
a plan yet um
and also
we have a contrast situation to figure
out but
i i want to point out the fact that
whether is a tizen fury or whatever
he can still happen under the ufc you
know uh when i said uh i want to box or
i want uh to fight tyson fury that
doesn't exclude exclude uh the usa you
know
he can't be under the ufc as long as we
have a
good contract a respectful term
that is
that has been agreed
uh by both party i think everything is
possible question let's just say you we
you continue with a contract let's just
say you renegotiate a contract with ufc
and the contract says it's all in but
you can't fight boxing the contract says
if i renegotiate the contract the
contract would technically says what i
want okay that's what mean negotiation
contract makes sense i mean
it's both party negotiating sure so uh i
have what i want they have what they
want and then uh negotiating i mean like
trying to compromise and find a middle
ground would one of the things be
important to you to be able to fight in
ufc and do boxing outside of ufc would
that be something that's important to
you
uh that's a possibility that's something
that's the option yeah
so so then then one of the questions for
me would be i remember the year where uh
uh jordan's playing in the nba and he's
not the highest-paid guy on the team and
a lot of other guys were following this
guy's you know strategy because he
wanted to win championships scotty was
making more money than him a lot of guys
weren't making more money than him
but the reason why it didn't matter for
him was because
you know he had a lot of sponsorship
money coming outside of the nba now
that's team sport you're not in a team
sport your team sport is you and your
coaches but it's not like you have a
team of you know 11 other teammates in
basketball that you're fighting
is it at a point where
fighters like yourself who are at the
pinnacle of their class are you getting
millions of dollars of sponsorship that
is coming through to you as well
uh my team are trying
so hard um
and they are doing a good job to find me
some sponsorship but you have to
understand like and this is one thing
under the ufc contract is very hard to
find a sponsor to have a sponsorship
because
uh they cover everything they kind of
like cut
you out from everything you can have a
proper sponsor because you can get in
the octagon or wherever with the sponsor
um
they recently have a sponsorship deal
with crypto.com um which is a big
crypto company
and that due
took a lot of money out of my pocket
because we were
this close to have a deal with um
uh cash up
so you can't now do cash and cash up is
a direct competitor
headline sponsor of the bitcoin event
that you're at this week
um
my about coinbase
coinbase
yeah yeah the big boys all the crypto
documents
the big boys yeah
and that's why
the the number was pretty good of course
right
so
they have that deal
with we literally like
cut our feet on the other side
lose a lot of money
but they are not living away do they
care about it
no
and that's how we we have to we struggle
with a lot of sponsorship here you know
when you have something you have it you
want a um
um
clothing company or
they're gonna be like oh you have this
in the octagon uh we can
be seen in the octagon so
technically we are whatever we do we are
just a second a plan b
for you
i mean even though it's not your choice
but that's how it is so it's
pretty hard for us to have a uh
sponsorship see for me
what other sport is like that by the way
where you can't get your own sponsors
outside of the sport
i mean you can you can have but it can't
be it's the right competitor
no it's very limited so can nike sign
you
nike concerning you but nike will sign
you because they want to uh benefit uh
from something they want to benefit uh
maybe especially or something but uh
one of the biggest moment that you're
exposed you will be wearing
some other brand
which is
direct competitor of nike so i'm like no
what i'm saying is so so michael jordan
signed with nike one day he comes home
his manager had he goes into his
manager's house i don't know if you've
heard the story or not michael jordan
comes to his manager's house he goes
straight to his closet he goes to the
closet he comes out grabs all his shoes
that are not nike grabs the scissors
starts cutting everything up he says
what are you doing he says you we were
only nike here he cuts him up he throws
them in the trash then sends him a box
of shoes to replace with all air jordans
to say we are
nike so there's maybe there's nothing
wrong with that to say you're
representing a brand but yeah
yes
but at the biggest stage you can't stand
by that brand
that you represent what does that mean
you can't stand by like like like
like when you step in the octagon for
example you can't wear nike in the
octagon no wait wait a minute that's the
thing wait wait i can't you you have no
right you have not you can wear
represent anything when you step in the
octagon it's just what the ufc provides
so
i have two paintings in my house of uh
art and senna and michael schumacher
right and i was talking about this
theater i said i said look at the power
of sponsorship because ceno's jersey
from 1989 is the sponsors of marlboro i
have it here 20 30 years later look at
the power of sponsorship right like the
power of giving senna 10 million bucks
because it's gonna be around forever
words in this house after he's no longer
with us so in nascar i can sponsor and
put a logo next to it half a million
dollars for a raise or half a million
depending on the race car driver who it
is right
so you mean to tell me you can't have
stuff on your shirt to say this is 10
grand
no no no is anybody renegotiating that
or no is anybody asking for that or is
that just the bylaws this is how it
works and that's it i think uh yes a
couple years ago i think it was what
maybe seven years ago they put that like
in the contra and this you know as many
things and this is
they were just like this is how it goes
and that's it and nobody has to say
anything
now the the return for that would be the
following like you know roger goodell
got that big godfather contract a few
years ago i don't know if you're
following it with the nfl go they'll got
this contract you know the good old
contract he goedel goedel is roger
goodell is the nfl commissioner right so
he gets the godfather contract
and it's 25 million a year unlimited
health insurance for his entire family
unlimited private jet for his entire
family i don't know what the contract
was a it's a 2 300 million contract by
the way at 25 million if you if you put
up just put roger goodell contract take
the godfather out 200 million dollar
contract right that he got now no team
owner
fought it nobody said anything but
here's why nobody fought it because
roger goodell brought the biggest
contract to the nfl media that a team
let's just say i own a team
went from being a 1.1 billion dollar
team to 2.8 billion dollar team you
roger goodell just maybe 1.7 billion
we'll pay you 25 million a year and
players officially got paid more so the
players liked godel making more money in
this case
if the brand is getting all this money
if the there's got to be an exchange so
let's just say you say yes it's okay for
nike and these guys to get it but your
pay also goes to xyz you're saying that
did not happen
nope
okay so then my next question would be
how much leverage do you have in
negotiating contracts
well
in negotiating contracts depend
um what can you ask for
you can ask everything that you want can
you what can you have can you wear a
nike shirt in there and fight can you
ask for anything i don't think so
because the way that they have structure
that's consciousness he stands as a he
stands now as a law like and nobody
talks about it you know there's hundreds
of fire
and everybody just comply
he's really hurt you know so
pat as a as a ceo yeah because right now
we're having a conversation with a
certified badass fighter ufc heavyweight
champion boom there he is but you're a
ceo you run a company with
how many thousands of
general independent contractors just
like he's an independent contractor he's
an employee of ufc
put yourself in dana white's shoes as
the ceo is the person that's bringing
the brand together yeah and now you're
dana white and you're you're sitting
here talking with the francis nagano's
of the world the conor mcgregors of the
world the jon jones of the world how do
you process what dana is going through
as a ceo saying sorry francis here's
what we're willing to do here's what
we're not willing to do through the mind
of a ceo well first of all ufc is not
ufc without dana white period whether
people like this guy or not it doesn't
matter i have so much respect for the
guy he has got a very hard job
hands down so to me
whatever they're paying dana they're not
paying them enough period that's a
that's not a 20 million dollar year ago
he's worth 350 400 whatever the payout
was when wm he bought him at three and a
half billion i think he was a 10 guy
maybe it diluted a little bit he got 300
million dana's a 50 million year guy he
needs to make that money period that's
that guy okay maybe i would even vouch
for him being 100 million guys some
people may disagree that's that so let's
set dana aside let's say dana's value
side you don't find people like dana
dana's a once-in-a-lifetime you know
generation type of a promoter and a
guide like a commissioner so you put
david stern there you put even godel
that's not like but he is getting the
money for the right guys there there's
only few people like him there right
okay so now let's set that part aside
the next part is
i i don't know i mean if you got 48
percent as the ebitda give or take their
margins are 35 to 50 percent you got the
margins to be able to afford to if they
get what they imagine the margins
margins are very high they make very
prof they make a lot of profit very
profitable ufc you say how much 48 is
the number we saw when we looked at our
reports
48 48
explain explain ebitda real quick just
yeah if you if you have to look at the
margins it's 35 to 48 percent we can
look it's public information no no no
you're saying it's higher
you mean what the usa is make of the
fighter no no no not fighter what ufc
makes
oh yeah what ufc not what you make so
for example your fight with ghani what
did you make you made a half a million
the margin um
paid a statistic that's going on now
like they make between
80 to 25 percent
they better did 85.
yes they made between but what i'm the
number i looked at is i looked at their
their financials where it shows
48
is so let's just say you do a dollar
they're making they're keeping 48 cents
that's the margins no but not on the
fights this is after employees staff
home office
compliance lawyers legal all of that
maybe not on the event staple but i mean
the whole organization
on the amount of money they you can see
their balance statement where do you
find it it's public information it's not
hard to find it's a formula earnings
before
uh uh what a depreciation
interest uh and amortization ebitda
taxes taxes
but but the point is they have room to
pay more they have room to pay more so
let me ask you
the the strategy you see because even
for somebody like you
you may say well i want to follow this
guy's playbook to get paid what i
believe i'm worth
who do you think has used the best
strategy in ufc to make the most money
outside of counter
it's really hard to use a strategy
in the ufc
uh
i think the way that the business is set
is set up like
they pay they pay you whatever they want
to pay you
they let you pretend that you're
negotiating while you're not negotiating
because either way you're staying in the
contract
like you will have a uh
let's say
40 months 40 months contract by the
by 20 months they will come to negotiate
a little bit more money if you say yes
yeah
then they are giving you a new 40 months
which means they start over because of
that because of the money
that they added
but because uh by that time your value
is like maybe
two or three times what they are
offering
you know
but
i mean you're kind of like broke you're
struggling and then uh
you're seeing your next fight okay 50
000
uh you have to pay this and pay that and
get away with maybe 20 000 and you have
to
pay your loan and all the staff and they
have a new contract hundred thousand
it's really hard to turn that down when
you're in that position yeah you know
even though you know that
that's not your value but you see you're
cornered you're cornered almost
so then let me let me ask this this
other question then
then and i think every and i think
everybody
uh in the ufc being in that position
does they always have a step ahead so
what if you go on strike i mean you just
you don't you don't want to do that
because that's not the right strategy
okay
you can go on strike
if you want to say that go ahead and
finish your thought yeah well no i just
could say you had the mlb strike the nfl
strike it's not the best way but if
you're backed into a corner what are
their options i don't think that's the
strategy what do you mean go on strike
like he's saying you 50 of you guys say
i'm not fighting until you pay me better
that's what he's saying going on the
strike protest yeah protests the top
guys in the ufc say we're not going to
fight we're not going to do any events
we're not going to do anything okay
until you meet what we what we're asking
for okay so this is the thing because
you were struggling you were expecting
your fight for the 50 000 yeah
which is which is what a lot of people
uh in the ufc they do and even for less
than that and they have uh
even
borrow money for uh
finance their training income or
whatever so they are expecting that
money to pay back and if you tell this
guy to go on strike
why he has a fifty thousand dollar
coming up who can like
save him from the guilting like release
his neck a little bit
come on twelve thousand dollars a lot of
money you're about to piss off francis
bro brother you're knocked out
no it's not it's not me i'm just trying
to explain you how he works so
therefore nobody really a lot of people
will not go on strike
not because
the ufc has the power to cut you
i'm going on strike oh really you're
doing that
you're out the right move no you're
doing that yeah you're out
then you don't even have that 50 000
anymore what next so a lot of
fighters they don't want to compromise
that because that
only what they get you know they don't
have a saving they live day by day fight
they fight and that's why like when they
don't fight
they go
they go dry
yeah so for me what i think about is how
you can add so the game plan what connor
did
connor has a drink proper 12 they sell
for 600 million i don't know what
percentage she owned a third of it he
got a couple hundred million dollars and
he was able to get a fight to be
sponsored by proper 12. so his drinks
out there he always sits there so there
mean that means there is some way to
leverage your brand so maybe a francis
in ghana may not be a
you know get sponsorships from nike or
adidas but maybe your camp is going to
come out with a product that you're
going to say hey let me build equity
around my product and let me leverage
ufc
to increase the value of this product
that i have and maybe i'll have an exit
of 50 million or 100 million or 300
million dollars maybe and that's what
i'm i'm sure that's what uh everybody
almost everybody in the ufc is doing
because you everybody at that point you
understand that you need another source
of income
but uh not everybody has a chance to be
in that position and to get things work
that's true you're right you know uh i
might be under i might be um
underestimate the sponsorship that i'm
having today not on the estimate but
believe that i could have better but
there's a lot of people that are just
dreaming to have what i'm having as far
as sponsorship because they don't even
have that
you know
so they have even less power
[Music]
not even to negotiate
even just to talk about it francis are
you getting more money from sponsorships
than fights right now
yeah okay is it is it four five ten
times more
is it ten times more
um
not yet
not yet okay got it it could be
yeah
like can can i hire like let's just say
if i'm a company can i hire you to do a
commercial on tv can i do that yeah okay
so then there is so so then it means
then that means that there's an
opportunity to have better managers to
manage talent to get things on tv for
example what what david what's uh
michael jordan's agent's name david
something david went to
nike when nike was only given 25 000 to
players every year he went to nike and
he said listen i know this is not the
model and i know this is not what you
need to do you need to pay one player
500 thousand dollars his name is michael
jordan so you
uh allowed me to enter please you are
going to like
pick in
like the top which is a few which is the
exception
how many people like michael jordan even
in the nba which is a very lucrative
sport
and very popular but but that but that
became a business model francis that's
what i'm saying how many people even to
today how many people that make his kind
of money yeah no 200 no wait a minute no
no in nba today yes 200 100. so no i
mean out of
uh
out of nba currently in the nba i can
tell you in the nba there's probably 50
they have 350 players 30 times 12 is
what 360. so they got 300 percent on the
team 18 i say 15 15 times 32 is what so
let's say 450. right yeah out of 450
a hundred of them 50 to 100 of them make
very good money outside of the mba
in the in outside outside of the mba
making very good money oh yeah i don't
agree with you okay
phew
made a lot of money outside of the nba
but no 250 no not even 100 i think 50
200 okay so maybe let's just say it's 50
that these guys get and then you have to
you have to um
remember
nba is like one of the most uh popular
sport
you know
it's not it's not the same thing here uh
with combat sport
uh fighters
they're literally like on their own they
have to do everything fight on their own
like it seems more like nba when you go
there when they uh hire you for a team
what you have to do is show up go train
you don't even need to find a house you
don't need to find anything that's true
yeah get everything set they get the
training set for you
you as a fighter you have to set
everything up you are on your own
because like yes you might have a
manager but what you're having
the the commission is not enough to
require somebody full-time or that
amount of job so it's way tough to a
fighter there is a fighter who will
train for who's the train for like
three months of training camp yeah go
out there fight for 10 and 10 or 12 and
12
in case you win you get like 20 000 or
24 or i don't know
26 but if you lose
you're going out there with 10 000 or 12
000
then you have to cut commission and tax
you find yourself out with
the average
is like
45 percent
45 percent of 10 000 or 12 000 is how
much nothing yeah for like three months
or twenty years
what's that being said on it
i just want to ask questions i know pat
has um let me ask you one thing yeah but
in in in the compensation structure of
individual sports that's pretty common
boxers don't make a lot of money many
golfers don't make a lot of money many
tennis players don't make a lot of money
so when you're in the top one percent
but the difference is i do agree that
the top one percent of tennis in the top
one percent of golf and the top one
percent of golfing makes way more money
than the top one percent of ufc that i
agree with
i think
uh i'm saying if in the usa that if the
top is one percent
then uh
in the ufc the top is
maybe zero point something
i had one quick question you're 34 about
to be 35 i'm 35. you're 35 already okay
my question is regarding your level of
urgency you're 35.
um
i think some of the best athletes in the
world are
their lifespans are being extended like
we talk about like lebron is 37 right
maybe he's got a couple years left aaron
rodgers just won the mvp 38 in the nfl
brady i think is gonna be 45 by the time
the season starts i think you still have
like people in the individual sports
like serena and roger federer that are
40. you're 35.
what's your level of urgency to get your
money now create your legacy now because
how much more time do you have left to
fight
um
i don't
see see it like a agency
you know um
i think everything
uh
comes with time everything comes with
with time
um
you just have to like
do gene right you know
i started the sport very late i didn't
have a chance or a opportunity to
practice paul
earlier in my life
but uh
from what i started i think i'm doing
pretty good
you know
i've been practicing sport for only nine
years and uh
i'm a world champion
and a lot of people have been practicing
for long long time and uh they are not
or not yet
a champion
you know so i don't think there's a
sense of
agency
i've you i do agree that uh i don't have
i'm not
very young for the sport but the fact
that i started late uh makes me like
been still being very
to be fresh you know as a athlete even
though i'm
40 i'm 30
35
i think a lot of people that are dirty
are more broken than i i am
you still got a lot of tread on your
tires is what you're saying yeah
that's what i'm saying francis let's
let's transition into a couple other
things jon jones you said this on uh
you said that jon jones finds a better
battle on twitter than in the ufc of
course a lot of people would love to see
the two of you guys fight now
weight wise i think he wants to go
heavyweight i think he's two oh four i
think you're six for 262. oh john johnny
is not 204
he's he's he's what i mean he always
been 204 or 205 when he caught weight to
go to
uh
to go to light heavyweight but his
everyday weight is not two or four what
do you think about it 220
oh way more okay basically like now that
he's gaining weight
john just now might be at least 250 to
16. okay 50
yeah article you're using says 240. yeah
so you guys are saying you're similar
weight class he wants to come up john
wants to come out he just got away to go
to light heavyweight
what what are the chances of him him
fighting you because
some would consider him the goat because
he's i think he's 27 and one i think
you're 17 and three yeah different style
of fighting what would happen if you and
jon jones fought
uh
i mean
without without camaro usman camaro on
the way i would consider jon jon as a
goat
me too
you put us man above him
um
yeah who's smaug over jon jones
are you saying that because you like
usman more than john jones or are you
saying no no i'm obviously yes that's
not visionable
but
this arguable but yeah i do agree that
john jones
could be
the greatest the good
all
not
you know
but
um i think fighting with him
uh
and i always think that
is gonna be a great great fight for me
a great test great challenge you know
because he's like um so by far the um
best um
how they say
um versatile all-around yeah yeah
complete fighting complete fighter yeah
skill secured and a complete fighter you
know you you just have to see how he
dominated on the light heavyweight in
the
past decade you know but don't you think
you're much bigger and stronger than him
and you could probably take even though
he's great and amazing but it's a
different way
strongest
is not enough
it's not enough really oh yo
it's not enough you have to bring
something
something way more than that to win the
fight you're fighting with a
professional who has a lot of experience
he has seen it all so
come on but you're confident if you face
him you you'd beat him yeah i'm
confident but
he's still like
he's
a challenge it's a very tough challenge
you know i know his skill set and i know
how dangerous he is you know so
yeah maybe the different question would
be the following are you more confident
going against
him
in a ufc match heavyweight your weight
or are you more confident going against
tyson fury in boxing
uh
i would say more confident going again
john jones because he's yes is a fear
that i uh mastered pretty good
than
boxing which is something that
professional boxing to be honest is
something that
i will be
a very
a newborn in that
in that film
but in mma as far as
today
i think i mastered that pretty good
so so more confident going against jon
jones than going against
tyson fury what about wilder
deonte wilder the guy that keeps
fighting tyson fury yeah do you have any
strong feelings about fighting him
yeah he's a
obviously that's a very interesting
fight because he's known for like
a one punch you know
and i think uh
that might be the opportunity to find
out who hit
the hardest yeah
so joe rogan here's what joe rogan said
here's what joe rogan said if this if he
was to fight uh tyson fear i don't know
if you've seen this or not joe rogan
said
he would murder tyson fury joe rogan
said this about joe rogan said he would
murder tyson fury he backs francis niga
nganu to
incapacitate tyson fury in the ufc of
course but not boxing oh yeah
it wouldn't even be fair in boxing it's
a different story if you win against him
uh uh and then you said here uh uh april
3rd just a few days ago you said i don't
really care about what it would be i
just want i just think it would be a
fight
you said i don't care if we fight
anywhere it could be in a phone booth or
in the rooftop that fight will happen so
you really want to fight tyson fury yeah
we've been going back and forth for over
two years now
and uh
[Music]
it's not a secret that my dream is
always to have a challenge in boxing
the
my dream has always been boxing even
before i discovered mma
you know so
at some point i want to experience that
to see where i am at
in boxing yeah yeah i think the whole
world would like to see that yeah by the
way which one do you want more which one
do you want more like you know because
there's like certain fights you want or
certain desires we have would you rather
have a fight against jon jones would you
rather fight against tyson fury
i could have both
you're not willing to pick one why why
should i pick why i could have both oh
so you want so you're greedy you want
both of them you don't just want one i
can't have both okay and even more it's
not like i'm not retiring no you're not
sure no you're 35. i'm gonna fight
a few a lot a lot of fight again you
know so yeah i can have both and even
someone that we are not even
expecting right now
uh by next year might be the biggest
fight or the biggest challenge or the
biggest opening
this just that just how the sport is you
know
[Music]
i don't have to choose
again to fight why i still have like
what
minimum of 10 fights in my
career
if it's not 20.
so john and tyson fury
have him both yeah he wants both half
both
and step over eight go maybe go find uh
deonte walder again oh
then and there will be another contender
somewhere maybe in mma
some
that
i will go find him
you know and by the way even with the
current contract can you do both like
even with the current ufc contract like
you know how jake paul comes out and
says why don't you come we'll pay you
better can you fight boxing and ufc
today
no in the current contract unless the
usa says so
unless if the ufc says so yeah so dana
has to give the green light
in the current contract wow
you bring up jake paul for a reason yeah
do you think everything he's doing is
actually pissing off dana white because
he calls him out he did a whole music
video
about dana white do you do you think
jake what are your thoughts on jake paul
and what he's doing ruffling those
feathers being a troll
louie what
ruffling dana white's feathers and
basically rattling the cage of dana
white what are your thoughts on what
jake paul is doing
well i think he's definitely pissing
pissing dana off
i would have been pissed off too
[Laughter]
yeah the way that uh
he he does it
yeah i would be pissed off
but i wouldn't do it do it that way or
in the same
fashion that he's doing it but
i find a lot of like
truth in what he says so a lot of truth
yeah and what jake paul is saying yeah
because he's kind of defending ufc
fighters
yeah
i mean
that's
that makes sense right and i think it's
a
it's something that um
we should think more about it at this
point of life are you saying that
secretly and maybe even not so secretly
a lot of ufc fighters are actually kind
of agreeing with jake paul and what he's
saying oh yeah a lot a lot
so many will not agree on the method
that he's doing it you know uh
the way that he's doing it
but
uh
the idea
yes interesting
have you watched jake fight or logan
fight have you watched both of them
last year i was even here when logan
fought uh a floyd mayweather what what
what did you think about both of us
no i was just thinking about the money
that he's cashing out
what what are we doing wrong yeah so so
you fighting if you got an offer to
fight joe uh jake or logan you'd be open
to it if the ufc allowed and the money
was there
i don't think
is the way class that could be what
happens if you had to fight both of them
at the same time yeah yeah funny
more sense but at the same time
yeah i gotta fight both at the same time
january of 2023 francis the god who vs
jake and logan paul same time knock it
both out no tyson fury first
i want it all you uh we have three
minutes left do you want to take a phone
call i think it's a pretty good question
well is it let's put them on yes go for
it
we have gill on the line
gil can you hear us
yes crystal clear fantastic what's on
your mind
alrighty so i had a quick question i
love francis he has an incredibly
inspirational life story thank you um i
wanted to know uh has anyone ever
approached you about making a movie
about your life or buying the rights to
your life story
and uh and part two is if so
uh who would who would you want to play
you that's a good question
um
yeah that's very interesting i think i
have that question already uh
but yes um
many one have um i have had a lot of a
few interests of like uh doing a movie
with my life or by the ride of
my
story even though as far as movie i
think is not time year you know um my
team and i we think like movie
should could wait we can
right now we are working on book and
documentary and the movie can wait
because like movie is kind of like oh i
have made it which is not where i am yet
you know i think there is
i agree a lot of range for me to go but
if that was the case um
what would i
would i like to play me maybe
idris erber interesting okay what about
will smith like i was about to say you
lost one character yeah idris would be
uh idris would be will smith in these
days no christmas
[Music]
honestly i never thought about
will smith but um
he might not be able to knock people out
these days but he'll slap a [ __ ]
oh yeah for sure
yeah but
yeah
what else we got john
no i get idris
okay idris this is my first pick at
least are you kidding me i fully see
that by the way i fully fully see that
because i've thought about it a lot oh
it's going to i hope this answer your
question will that's
yeah yes thank you well appreciate the
caller calling in
uh uh francis appreciate you for coming
out really enjoyed it man what a story
you got and we're looking forward to
watching you fight hopefully by the end
of the year because you kind of did say
i can fight end of 2022. yeah
december
this will be good and he wants all the
smoke he wants he wants tyson fury he
wants deante wilder he wants jon jones
and throwing a couple of the paul
brothers while we're at it i have a lot
of years ahead of me and i'll have a
couple of fights that i don't even know
what
who they're going to be so yes while
we're here if i can pick two trees why
not may as well do it
anyways gang hope you enjoyed it as much
as we the friends appreciate you for
coming out man this was fantastic yes
this was fantastic okay what do we have
you're saying we got uh tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow we've got andrew yang
and dave rubin dave rubin every morning
in the afternoon same time not same time
one will be in the morning what don't be
in the afternoon uh have a great one
everybody and i have a feeling are you
going to the bitcoin conference you're
going to be at the bitcoin conference
that's why i'm here you know you're
going to confirm you're speaking at the
bitcoin conference right there's some
event you're doing right okay
so some of you guys may see the champ at
the bitcoin conference thank you
everybody we'll see you guys
yeah that's
right
you know i like it yes of the future i
like you know i love money from pay this
man his money right right okay thank you
everybody bye bye bye
you